Імпровізований табір біженців завдовжки кілька кілометрів: намети та багаття.
Так цими днями виглядає білорусько-польський кордон у районі пропускного пункту Кузниця.
Увага, увага. Повідомлення поліції: переходити польський кордон можна лише через пропускний пункт.
Це кадри з польського боку, де близько 17 000 польських прикордонників відтісняють мігрантів, що скупчилися біля кордону.
Ті намагаються прорватися крізь колючий дріт, солдати застосовують сльозогінний газ та кийки.
У вівторок, 9 листопада, на кордоні з Білоруссю побував прем'єр-міністр Польщі Матеуш Моравецький.
Хто б міг подумати ще два-три місяці тому, що ми матимемо справу з використанням людей як живих щитів.
Режим Лукашенка використовує мирних жителів як зброю гібридної війни.
Те, що ми бачимо сьогодні, - це нові методи, і ви є ключовим бастіоном проти них.
Раніше міністерство оборони Польщі оприлюднило відео, на якому видно, що за парканом з колючого дроту пересуваються люди у формі,
ймовірно, білоруські військові.
А ось кадри з іншого боку кордону.
За різними оцінками, у таборі на польсько-білоруському кордоні перебувають від кількох сотень до кількох тисяч біженців
з країн Близького Сходу та Африки. Вони намагаються прорватися до Польщі, а звідти ще далі.
Ми йдемо не до Польщі, ми йдемо до Німеччини. Ми хочемо до Німеччини. Не до Польщі.
Доступ до біженців мають лише офіційні білоруські та російські ЗМІ.
За їхніми повідомленнями, у таборі є вагітні жінки та маленькі діти.
Їжі та ліків не вистачає, а температура повітря вночі опускається нижче нуля.
Польща запровадила надзвичайний стан у прикордонному регіоні
та обмежила доступ журналістів та представників гуманітарних організацій до місця подій.
Важливо наголосити, що журналісти не можуть перебувати на місці подій уже з середини вересня.
Вся інформація, якою ми користуємося, надходить у ЗМІ від влади.
Так само, як і ці кадри, які ми бачили напередодні.
Так, уряд пояснює недопуск журналістів загрозами безпеці.
Однак дехто такий підхід критикує.
На їхню думку, влада не хоче, щоб усе, що відбувається на кордоні, бачив хтось з боку.
Гібридна атака керівництва Білорусі за підтримки Москви.
Так в один голос називають те, що відбувається на кордонах ЄС, офіційні особи в Німеччині, Євросоюзі та НАТО.
У Брюсселі переконані, що хвиля мігрантів із Близького Сходу організована особисто Олександром Лукашенком.
Зрозуміло, це продовження відчайдушної спроби режиму Лукашенка використати людей як пішаків для дестабілізації
Європейського Союзу та цінностей, які ми відстоюємо.
Польщу не залишили наодинці з міграційною кризою.
Потужні сигнали підтримки звучать як з Брюсселя, так і з боку окремих країн-членів ЄС.
Глава МВС в уряді Німеччини схвалив дії Варшави, зокрема плани щодо укріплення прикордонних споруд.
Згуртуватися мають усі країни ЄС, оскільки Лукашенко, за підтримки президента Росії Володимира Путіна,
використовує людські долі, щоби дестабілізувати Захід.
Тому ми маємо діяти згуртовано. Польщі чи Німеччині самим із цим не впоратися.
Єврокомісія терміново відрядила своїх представників до країн, звідки прибули біженці.
Щоб переконати громадян цих країн, як наголосили в ЄС, "не потрапляти у пастку білоруської влади".
Євросоюз, крім того, має намір внести до чорних списків авіакомпанії тих країн, які доправляють мігрантів до Білорусі.
Близько двох десятків авіакомпаній - під моніторингом.
У тому числі з арабських країн, Африки та Росії.
Також у Брюсселі оголосили, що готують нову порцію санкцій щодо Мінська.
Наразі їх погоджують країни-члени ЄС.
Я закликаю держави ЄС нарешті схвалити розширений санкційний режим щодо білоруської влади за цю гібридну атаку.
Чому ми вважаємо, що санкції кусаються? Тому що режим Лукашенка починає поводитися як гангстерський режим.
Санкції завдають їм болю, і вони не знають, що робити, та намагаються підірвати Європейський Союз
запуском гібридної атаки проти однієї з країн-членів ЄС.
Так, ми вважаємо, що санкції працюють. І ще більше санкцій уже на підході.
Європейці побоюються повторення міграційної кризи 2015 року, яка завдала Європі серйозної політичної шкоди.
Проте вирішення проблем на зовнішніх кордонах Польщі ускладнюють напружені відносини Брюсселя та Варшави.
Правлячі праві популісти у Польщі, попри бажання Єврокомісії, відмовляються запрошувати до країни представників "Фронтекс" -
європейського агентства з охорони зовнішніх кордонів.
Його допомога необхідна, аби безпечно повернути мігрантів додому, щоб уникнути гуманітарної катастрофи.
Зростаюча концентрація військових сил з обох боків польсько-білоруського кордону також непокоїть Європу.
Як заявили в штаб-квартирі НАТО, Мінськ застосовує "гібридну тактику" стосовно членів Північноатлантичного альянсу - Польщі, Литви та Латвії.
Однак про застосування статті 5-ої про союзницьку допомогу поки не йдеться.
Лише у Берліні сигналізували готовність відрядити на кордон німецьких поліцейських, якщо такий запит надійде з Варшави.